when somebody asks you where you're from
that is their attempt to be friendly
that's them trying to form a human
connection with you
that's another human being reaching out
to you a fellow human being in an effort
to relate to you and get to know you
if this irritates you or offends you
that's a sign of something wrong inside
of you
you're the problem
[Music]
today our cancellation begins with a
person whose name is a fun riddle for
someone like myself who infamously has
so much trouble pronouncing names i'll
take one pass at this and we'll go with
whatever pronunciation happens to pop
out the name is
raksha
vasudevan raksha vasudevan there we go
she's a writer for the new york times in
vice and she's certainly the kind of
person who would not be at all amused by
me making jokes about her
unpronounceable name in fact miss v as
we'll call her recently went viral with
a tweet about the harrowing challenges
immigrants face in this country she
posts a picture of a sign that her uber
driver had posted in his car and she
captions
seen in today's uber thinking of making
a duplicate to hang around my neck and
then the sign says which the uber driver
posted dear passenger please do not ask
me where are you from
the where are you from question
conversation makes me sick frustrated
and uncomfortable thanks for your
understanding
now
until the same parts of twitter got a
hold of this tweet and started
responding which led miss v to deleting
it entirely many of the responses were
from other immigrants applauding the
uber driver and voicing their agreement
i think just one example should suffice
a woman named keon julie wang who
identifies herself as ex-undocumented as
well as a a litigator a vegan yogi and
an obsessive dog mom
all those
from her directly chimed in with this i
once had a white uber driver ask me this
and when i said here
he said obviously we all live here now
but where are you really from i ignored
him and he asked again louder i said i
wasn't comfortable answering nor talking
he got very angry louder and insisted it
was a very fair topic of convo and why
wouldn't i just answer him it was so
scary i had to call my husband and keep
him on the phone the whole ride
psa to white people you are not entitled
to interrogate the personal history of
bypoc or any random human for that
matter the only time i welcome this
question is when a new asian immigrant
is looking to bond chat in a possibly
shared first language many koreans
mistake me for korean which i take as a
compliment i once got scolded by an old
korean lady in k-town for abandoning my
mother tongue
oh you see if you're white then you
don't have permission to speak to her
but if you're asian then you can
actually go up to her and scream at her
and she'll take it as a compliment
i can only hope that this woman's
husband explained to her that the uber
driver was annoyed because she was being
incredibly rude
but i think we can be fairly certain
that uh she would not have married the
kind of man who would tell her the truth
in situations like this or in any other
situation her husband is likely as
neutered as her dogs are we might assume
but in the event this this all is quite
common among young leftist immigrants i
don't say that it's common among
immigrants in general
most immigrants have probably never
heard of the concept of microaggressions
and once they do hear about it they
begin to second guess their decision to
come to this confused society in the
first place but on the left
it's considered a microaggression and
othering
if you say anything to a foreigner which
acknowledges that they are foreigners
they
don't want to talk about that aspect of
themselves
except for all the times when they do
want to talk about that aspect of
themselves in fact miss v's bio on her
website says this
born in india and raised in canada
raksha vasudevan is a writer and former
aid worker
that's the very first sentence of her
biography
the first thing she wants anyone reading
her bio to know is that she was born in
india
and yet she doesn't want it to come up
in casual conversation
the self-contradiction is evident across
the board the left of course
relentlessly insists that we celebrate
immigrants minorities quote unquote
bypoc etc and yet at the same time we're
not necessarily given permission to
notice that anyone actually is an
immigrant or minority
they'll tell us that um you know that
they will tell us when we're allowed to
notice it and in what way and what we
can and cannot say when we do notice it
if we've been
given permission to notice it at all
we find a very similar dynamic with
sexual orientation and gender identity
because on the one hand
the gay leftists or the trans leftists
they go to extraordinary lengths to
advertise their lgbt membership
and they demand to be celebrated and
worshiped for it
but on the other hand just because
you're required to celebrate it
doesn't mean you're allowed to ask them
about it
or talk about it or make note of it
again they will make the rules that
govern how you can speak to them or
speak about them
and the rules are subject to change any
time without notice
you must not only follow the rules
but figure out a way to read their minds
so that you can know the rules ahead of
time because you also can't ask them
about the rules you can't do that
you just you just have to know you have
to you have to sense it intuitively
is this one of those moments when
it's a microaggression for me to ask
them about their identity or is it a
microaggression to not ask them
well you just have to you have to know
you have to read their mind
this is how they believe human
interactions work and they're wrong so
let me explain the reality
and i'm speaking now directly to miss v
if she happens to see this here's what
you need to know
first of all when somebody asks you
where you're from
that is their attempt to be friendly
that's them trying to form a human
connection with you
that's another human being reaching out
to you a fellow human being in an effort
to relate to you and get to know you
if this irritates you or offends you
that's a sign of something wrong inside
of you
you're the problem
that's your hang up that's your issue at
best it's a pet peeve
but here's the thing about pet peeves
they're your problem
i feel the same about pet peeves as i do
about actual pets
you can have them lots of people do but
don't make them my problem
okay i don't care if you have a dog i
just i don't want to have to listen to
him or find his uh find his defecation
on my lawn
keep it to yourself
except in this case it's worse than a
pet peeve
because it's ego which causes you to be
offended by basic questions about
yourself this is your own
weird little narcissistic impulse now
you may tell yourself that because you
don't want to talk about yourself in
these situations it's actually the
opposite of narcissism but that's not
the case it's narcissism because you
again like any leftist you believe that
you have the right to set the rules for
the conversation
you think you can and should control
what people say to you
you want to set the parameters not just
on what strangers say to you but on how
they perceive you
sometimes you want to be
be perceived as an immigrant other times
you don't
and you think the rest of the world has
to just
dance along to whatever tune you happen
to be humming at any given moment
no
that's not the world's responsibility
the responsibility in fact goes the
other way
it is your responsibility to suppress
and manage
your personal hang-ups and unreasonable
irritations so they don't become a
burden on other people
you must conform yourself to the
standards of a civilized society society
isn't going to conform to you
random strangers on the street they
don't know about your ridiculous pet
peeves
all they know is that you're another
person a fellow human being
they might try to strike up conversation
because they want to know more than that
they want to connect with you
and in your case they'll quickly learn
that the most pertinent facts about you
are that you're rude unpleasant overly
sensitive manipulative and controlling
but at least they'll never find out
exactly where you're from so
you get your way in that respect i
suppose
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content